bitte vertraut mir einfach bei dem was
ich euch jetzt sage wenn du ein
komplettes Glas getrocknetes Format mit
Öl in einem mixgefäß gibt eine
Knoblauchzehe Senf und Honig sowie ein
Eigelb etwas Salz und Pfeffer die in den
Mixer Schnaps und das ganze
durchpürierst
dann erhältst du den wahrscheinlich
leckersten Brotaufstrich Mayo Dip den du
dir nur vorstellen kannst ab aufs Brot
ausstreichen ist das womit ihr wollt mit
Pommes mit allem ich sage euch ehrlich
ich habe es gerade probiert komme ich
auf mein Leben klar das ist wirklich mit
einer der krassesten Sachen die wir
gezeigt haben bisher so schnell so
lecker komplette